une heure de dire moi j'ai un
rendez-vous [__] mais je vais me
plaindre à la police aux gendarmes mais
vous êtes complètement con merde alors
attendez
ah bah oui c'est parce que j'étais à la
selle allez hop vous allez m'en dire des
nouvelles
c'est très bien
mélanger
[Musique]
comme ça
un petit goût de fruits
il est très très sucré et c'est
effectivement il y a des il y a de la
vanille pistache
un petit goût de cornichon
c'est parce que vous savez c'est il
presse le raisin avec les pieds alors
comme il y a des champignons donc on met
beaucoup d'alcool pour enlever les
microbes
pour faire passer le goût
[Applaudissements]
avec modération pas plus de 3 litres on
sent allez bonne journée monsieur
en tout cas ton gant il est génial
je suis vraiment
[Musique]
c'est courtier je te confier c'est la
chanson
trésorier
12 minutes 12 minutes madame venez avec
nous madame venez avec nous
Paris
ça y est nous venons de trouver le
premier indice
dans le salon tu auras la moins qu'on le
[__] le salon le salon vite le salon
vous rentrez pas tous dans la maison
c'est la chanson trésor monsieur
vous pouvez nous dire où se trouve
le trésor
l'indice on a 8 minutes Paris 7 minutes
bonjour monsieur le poulailler le
poulailler s'il vous plaît
c'est la concentré trésor vite il est
là-bas vite
il reste 8 minutes 10 minutes comment
sont les œufs paris les œufs sont jaunes
non c'est pas celui-là je la tape top
Paris
oh non c'est pas le bon il faut
pas cacher
voilà nous avons l’œuf jaune dans le
salon tu suivras mes instructions
le salon le salon venez suivez-moi
on remettra tout après
Paris nous avons trouvé le troisième
indice dans la cuisine va fouiller dans
la farine la cuisine
vite vite vite
attention
alors
[Musique]
dans le jardin cherche le parchemin
traversant merci beaucoup
parce que là sinon il ne reste plus que
2 minutes
nous avons donc la quatrième et dernière
énigme je suppose
dans la chambre à coucher tu vas trouver
doucement oh là là
c'est la carte top c'est la carte c'est
la carte du Trésor Paris
je vais aller manger ailleurs
c'est bon de purin
c'est pour déverser ici
vous pouvez pas chercher
vous allez à Rouen
vous allez prendre la nationale du
poisson
l'autoroute est plus vite non
tout seul dessus vous pouvez pas prendre
l'autoroute avec ça avant c'est à partir
du moment où c'est pas une matricule
vous avez pas de carte grise
nationale
prenez les Champs-Élysées sont juste en
dessous
vous allez prendre la finale faut
combien de temps en tracteur merci
au revoir bonjour
alors il me faudrait un rosbif dans le
filet vous avez ça pour 12 mais bon il y
a des bons mangeurs mettez-moi pour 15
d'accord
je vais demander à ma femme quand même
je serai plus tranquille comment ça ils
viennent pas oh là là mais tu aurais dû
m'appeler plus tôt là je suis chier le
boucher là il vient de couper le rosbif
c'est pour combien là
vous avez coupé
alors on fait quoi alors 4 4 pour 4
personnes
monsieur et avec avec trois tu lui as
fait couper un rosbif pour 10 personnes
en trois attends mais le prends pas sur
ce ton écoute tu fais ce que tu veux
alors oui ben voilà tu bouffes avec tes
parents c'est très très bien ouais c'est
ça allez ciao bon bah je suis désolé
je vais prendre pour moi là parce que je
suis tout seul
du jambon vous savez
un peu avant allez-y
il y en a combien là
je veux celle-là celle que vous avez
dans la main
non non seulement
la dernière
vous me faites bouger du jambon
qu'est-ce que c'est ce travail et les
autres alors je vais manger moi on va
faire des endives au jambon
je vous la compte 120
[Musique]
vous allez me lever tous mes câbles
surtout que je suis pressé j'ai
rendez-vous
attention malheureusement vous avez tout
me décaler non mais on croit rêver
[Applaudissements]
c'est la carte j'ai une carte
moi je téléphone pas je sors ma voiture
c'est un parking ça y a 1000 voitures
là-dedans pourquoi ils m'ont dit de le
mettre là moi
vous voyez pas qu'il y a une cabine
téléphonique
je vous laisse faire parce que moi je
veux pas que mon patron il voit ça
allez-y allez-y allez-y
Léo
on la prend là non attention le plexi
monsieur non respect non vous avez cassé
attention attention
vous êtes en train de
d'embêter tout le monde avec votre
portable
encore encore encore
voilà comme ça c'est bon allô Roger tu
peux revenir là parce que il semblerait
qu'on ait mis la cabine où il fallait
pas ok on est là d'ici une heure une
heure une heure vous pouvez pas plus
vite parce qu'il y a un monsieur qui est
qui est coincé
à la police au gendarmes mais vous êtes
complètement con merde alors oui pas que
c'est la sortie de parking
[Applaudissements]
il sort du parking il y a une cabine en
plein milieu c'est stupide mais pas la
mettre là ouais mais là il y a un poteau
on peut pas la mettre devant le poteau
pas sur la voiture malheureusement
possible merde vous êtes pas doué c'est
pas moi
c'est pas important
c'est pas important ça c'est
que cette
fanfaronnade ça c'est de la fin on a de
comme vous dites pourquoi
vous mettez votre cabine ici je
comprends pas c'est pas moi ah bon
merci Monsieur allez
quand même
vous êtes tellement sympathique
salut
[Musique]
parce que je suis tombé amoureux de toi
tu es habillé comme moi en noir et blanc
allô
j'appelle pas dans une cabine là non
dans une voiture
bon arrêtez de déconner passez-moi le
docteur s'il vous plaît
vous appelez dans une Fiat 500 ah c'est
toi Richard c'est toi non tu peux pas
t'empêcher de faire le con hein
vous êtes en retard
déposer le sac dans la voiture
fermer la porte
voilà maintenant parti en courant
[Musique]
cette histoire
pour toi Maman c'est quelqu'un pour toi
et c'est ton âge mon enfant
alors ouais
tu pleures
super fort en casque
je te propose un défi
comme ça tu jettes en l'air et tu le
rattrapes sur la tête
tu vas faire l'amour avec la petite
c'est tout quoi c'est tout
[Musique]
ah non je l'ai pas vu monsieur
regardez il y a rien écrit
[Musique]
de quelqu'un là-dedans
faut frapper avant d'entrer
pourquoi vous m'envoyez des bouteilles
dans la gueule
m'envoyer des bouteilles vides j'en ai
pris une sur la tête
c'est ma maison
[Musique]
de ma gueule ou quoi c'était de ma
gueule là-dedans
je peux le prendre
deux bouteilles 4 francs depuis quand
depuis cette semaine c'est pour
sensibiliser les gens à mettre les
bouteilles en verre dans le container
parce que moi celui-là toute la journée
en plus j'ai très soif et les gens ils
mettent que des bouteilles vides dites
dedans
il faudrait manger à manger c'est du
sucre
il faut aussi du sucre
c'est gentil
mais ça c'est pas assez sucré
[Musique]
une pêche
ça va mieux là
mettez-moi un petit kilo alors
[Applaudissements]
il est pas là
les abricots sont bons c'est bon vous
êtes mieux maintenant
je suis plus tranquille je suis à côté
du Sud
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça à côté
aussi c'est pareil vous mangez un peu
ici un peu fort mais c'est le temps que
vous arrivez
vous êtes malade je veux pas faire
c'est gentil laisse-moi travailler
deux phrases monsieur s'il vous plaît
sois gentil
un petit bout de pastèque
j'ai rien du tout
ou quoi merci
je m'en fous c'est pas mon problème
bon d'accord puisque vous avez dit s'il
vous plaît je m'en vais là merci un
petit bisou ça va pas non salut
tu veux goûter c'est un nouveau produit
qu'on lance sur le marché
qui coûte super bon
l'aspect vous le trouvez comment
ça marrant
des médicaments
[Applaudissements]
la gerbe qui fait une étude de marché
sur c'est du concentré de pruneaux quand
même c'est un cachet c'est l'équivalent
d'un kilo de pruneaux
un quart d'heure ça va commencer
[Musique]
équivaut à peu près à 1 kg de pruneaux
bon donc je vais prendre votre nom
vraiment madame vraiment non non faut
vraiment que vous preniez mon nom
[Applaudissements]
la taille
de toi
on est en ça fait aller
allez-y doucement les enfants parce que
vous allez faire caca partout avec ça
[Musique]